so I'm Consulting for the co the other
day he's super nervous very antsy
anxiety sigh I'm watching for him he's
about to ask the question and he's
sweating us and he's about to tell me
he's going through a divorce his wife
left him you know he's filing bankruptcy
one of his employees took his money and
he doesn't have anything left but no he
says Pat all of a sudden our business
doubles in size we did 16 million
dollars I've never met this kind of
profit before I've never had this kind
of money before I have no clue what to
do so think his business has grown the
business owner's dream he's making more
money than ever before but he's nervous
so I asked him one question that took
the conversation to a whole different
direction but by the way if you get
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up and subscribe to the channel let's
get right into it I ask him is your
business at 16 million doubled in size
because of the current climate of the
market because of you or because of a
client or a employee so he says uh no
the business is at 16 million dollars
and we're making this kind of money
because the market the market is so hot
I've never gotten this much business in
my life before I'm not doing anything
different and I didn't hire anybody new
and it's not because of a new customer I
said okay do you want the good news or
do you want the bad news he says Pat I
have a feeling it's only going to be bad
news I said well I said the good news is
you're about to make a lot of money the
next three six months save a lot of that
money but the bad news is this is going
to go by very quickly and your business
is going to drop 50 back to what it
normally has been the last five years
for the following reason the market can
change all the time there's a lot of
guys in real estate and mortgages that
made a lot of money during that 160
month economic expansion I know a lot of
people will say well no it was only 128
months interrupted by covet if there is
no covet that 128 is more like 160 150
economic expansion so many Realtors
mortgage loan officers made so much
money drove all the Lambos to Ferraris
all the cars and they got nothing left
to themselves because of the market only
few of them are still in business
growing because of them so the three
questions was what the market you or
last but not least is what one client or
one employee why one client one employee
say you got one client all of a sudden
brings a business to you hey you know we
got so much business going on you seem
to be able to process our business we'd
like to bring 10 million dollars of our
business over to you you're doing six
million a year one company brings 10
million but if that company leaves you
to somebody else you can also very
quickly go from 16 million to 6 million
because that person is going to got 10
million or if you brought one sales
person on board and that's salesperson
brought all their customers from another
company to you but you only got two
sales people or three sales people if
that salesperson leaves so will the
revenue follow that salesperson to
whatever company they're going to the
only saving grace you have for your
company to continuously grow and I can
tell you most people don't want to hear
this because most people want the
shortcut the yeah but if you don't
understand but what if what if it's
because I know what to do and I don't
have to work as hard and I'm doing the
six days a week off and I want to do
this and no man you just got lucky a lot
of people get lucky there's a reason
most businesses don't make it there's a
reason most business to file bankruptcy
there's a reason most businesses shut
down three five years there is a reason
for that it's a very very hard how many
restaurants from 10 mile radius of where
you live right now have been around for
20 years why do you think because it's a
very very hard to run a business and
those who have been around for 20 years
there's typically a great operator
behind closed doors that's dependable
reliable that's driving the company so
I'm going to come back to you here if
you're watching this you're a business
owner and the times may be good for you
it may be bad for you you may be like
this guy you all of a sudden are making
more money than ever before thinking
it's because of you but it's because of
the market if you'd like to protect that
so you don't ever have to worry about
that business going away for you take
inventory of what you can do to recreate
yourself as a leader as an operator as a
creative marketer as a way to make the
investment into the right people whether
it's not just one client that you're
relying on you don't ever want to have a
client or a salesperson that gives you
more than 20 percent of your revenues
per year if it is maybe 25 percent my
number is typically 20 if it's above 25
percent if they own fifty percent if
that guy leaves you don't really have a
business that person owns you the
customer owns you the employee owns you
the market owns you you don't own your
business they own you so you got to flip
it on them you got to be so good at what
you do that the market no crisis no
individual no customer no client no
sales person working for you can dictate
the future of your company if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel by the way
if you haven't yet downloaded minute I
get questions asked all the time on my
neck I get thousands of messages on
Instagram Twitter Facebook I never get
back to I don't have the time to get
back to it but I get back to a hundred
percent of my messages on my neck
because you want to connect with me I
got to give you my time you got to pay
for it if you want to talk to me or you
want to talk to Tom or other influencers
and experts on my neck about raising
money about business about recruiting
about whatever it may be download the
app connect we're going to put the link
below here or somewhere here you can
click on and you can text me and I'll
respond back text me and I'll respond
back in a video or we can do a 15-minute
FaceTime together if it's not me you can
do with other people on minute having
said that have a great Everybody Take
Care bye-bye bye-bye
[Music]